the Westminster Avenue public school in
the low-income community of Venice
California
Miriam Van Osdol for 23 years a
dedicated teacher now she offers her
classroom as a laboratory for an
experiment in education Noreen Nelson a
teacher for 13 years Frank Gehry her
brother a professional architect
together they have developed a way of
using architecture and town planning to
teach fifth grade Merriam vanarsdel
students will join in the pilot project
for one school year their experience
will raise fundamental questions about
teaching we developed purium as a way of
really getting started something to
initiate the project and we give them a
a problem to build a city in three hours
and we've just put the pressure on like
mad in this three hours and at the end
they've resolved some of the problems
but not all of them and they are totally
involved in the city building process
and the name purium just came out of the
blue we just were trying to think of
some reason why you would have to build
a city on this piece of cardboard and we
developed a little scenario that the
world needed some kind of thing to make
trash biodegradable and purium was that
mineral and it was discovered in the
mountains behind this piece of land and
that a nice farmer who'd been there for
30 years was willing to give up his land
for the good of mankind and that orders
were coming in from all over the world
the world was worrying for years about
how to get rid of their trash and the
scientists came in and they found their
period since purium has been discovered
here what's gonna be here pretty soon
building a city right like do you want a
lot of people crabby to around okay
what's that word crowd Wow isn't it
coming over anything else you don't want
enemies enemies yeah okay that's very
good and I like that word okay now Danny
nice cars but what's it gonna be called
the main heading that we're gonna talk
about monorail no but what are you gonna
need to use the people around and you
see here's a good idea because you can
see here that you need transportation
but you can see over here that you don't
want cars and trucks and buses and
airplane so since you're future people
today you will invent a new
transportation system whatever you
decide on whatever you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay what about the traffic we said we
didn't we didn't want to have cars
trucks too many roads oh how about our
purium city we have that are we gonna
have traffic problems there yes big x-3x
there no but we lost a lot of trees so
we lost on end
[Music]
now when you get fires and traffic and
overpopulation and no trees
do you have wars and enemy not wars
maybe but at least a lot of people are
nervous aren't they - well how would you
guys like to keep working on cities for
the rest of the year yeah I'm gonna come
back and talk to you again see how
you're doing I don't know I felt that
the kids really got into it but that
they were held back a little bit I shall
I personally felt somewhat intimidated I
didn't know exactly why at the time but
I felt like I was being watched
carefully and I guess it turned out
later to be mrs. Van Arsdale who was
watching me I had not been filled in as
to what would happen
I'd inquired wanted to be a part of it
but the feeling was that it was
important that the class and I'd not be
that it occurred on the spot which it
did we accomplish much more on the trend
the transit day was the best day for me
yes but in terms of learning of kids I
saw kids doing mathematics in areas I'd
never seen before in that group
I had what came
that's fantastic that's all and what are
we doing we're just computing all the
intersections all the angles right
somebody get down there with a stick
right now that's curve yeah everybody
look into the stick
[Music]
okay come on over see that's there
that's lined up perfectly on those zeros
it's like the protractor
right this is like that though this was
lay down there
[Music]
Rose there's more in 100 there's 18 270
and 312 42.2 inches the be 2.2 inches
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I want you to remember the things you
decided about changing the levels
because you can't forget that and I
think this Center so they should have
they should they should immediately
write down every building they build and
its purpose so we have a little record
of it what did you forget
[Music]
forgot something how do we get around in
the city great things about Sanders they
could cut and change levels whereas in
the classroom they had to deal with only
a flat surface and build blocks on top
of it here they had ability to cut deep
holes and and get a vertical relations
vertical changes in relationship I
thought that was the most successful day
we hand what's the with the school and I
think the major reason it was the most
successful day was that mrs. Van Arsdale
got into it that thing she didn't uh-huh
ah dice is funny I got the whole
different feeling I thought she was
really participating I think she
probably didn't like that day because I
structured part of it I started building
a hole I see that there could have been
a lot more I think the far better
results is if more time has been
involved in planning involving the the
children from the beginning and what was
happening rather than sort of surprising
them with things I'm Tony and I'm
running for mayor at a new Oakland
Community why why because I want I want
tall buildings and I want more parts
where we just gotta make some move one
little building how do we need what do
you want big building nor audience won't
one big villain death won't be in the
middle of Nemea how do you get to live
yeah we felt that the child who we as
adults saw as best suited to be the
mayor of the final City ought to receive
some preferential attention in preparing
the speech for that campaign for mayor
there was pressure from the group
involved from the people working with
the school to through the grant to
particularly youngsters picked for the
political offices I don't know for what
reasons camera more photogenic or more
outgoing or verbal kinds of youngsters
it just wasn't in keeping with what
would be normal procedure in school or
out as for mayor they picked a youngster
who hasn't shown leadership potential
according to what has been seen in the
past and yet it was all there in some
[Music]
[Music]
terrible and they didn't really care how
they made it as long as they got it
built once we've defined the overall
parcel but there to work within a game
now is to break them down into
individual plots give each child a plot
that's his but in order to plan it in
order to plan for the greater good of
the whole he's got to resolve his
differences with the other students they
have to decide what happens on their
mutual property lines how they're gonna
put a road through and so on that is the
planning process when it was heading in
the direction of the small parcels of
land very definitely felt that there
should be from the beginning more just
more group together nests and the whole
thing more overall planning was if the
children had a chance to do the entire
planning for a piece of property and
this is something that part of today's
world part of it is that is how land is
divided in real life and that is one of
the biggest conflicts in in our cities
is that the private ownership of land do
you think it's gonna be possible to
build some projects by getting together
and forgetting it up the lines or you
think it's everybody's gonna have to
build on their own they said we should
keep things separate if there's
something wrong with keeping them what's
wrong it won't be as steady basically
keep separate only something really
important like possibly that's really
important really or need a lot of so
Mike what you're saying is you don't
want 38 separate if you want to look
youth united I wonder 114 this is a will
be exciting to make a real big football
one of the things we talked about is the
city's get all fouled up because people
don't work together and that was one of
the things we're not trying to boy try
them all work together
does that make sense she had a very hard
time working together and tell your
story there isn't is it too much from
there all kinds of transportation
fellows no I'd rather not I think I've
told you enough times what is the
problem is alright yes I'll be happy to
lack of planning lack of foresight poor
judgment as far as working with
youngsters are concerned the teachers
lack of involvement to be able to help
with the architect which is the premise
of the entire thing I think it's
extremely unfortunate to a group of
children or very capable that they have
not been given the fair chance for this
year that they were promised at the
beginning we've had effective people in
here there are times when you have had
excellent rapport I don't know what's
happened but you absolutely kill any any
kind of creativity I come in where
speaking to be a person who knows
getting your personal I see well I and I
think that the new create attention and
the kids that makes it impossible to get
to them they're mayor of the town came
to me the other day and said that the
circle building was my idea right and
therefore he told yeah they told me and
the flower building also they had been
our buildings but they did what I was
trying to imposing ideas upon I'm an
architect and I have that I have
solutions to things you have better
ideas I maybe said no I would hope I
would hope help children to do this it's
happened over and over trying to rig my
election within the kids they came up
with beautiful choices why do these
kinds of things
why impose ideas the eraser suggested an
and I made I want to make eraser
monument to pollution which Doreen took
and threw in the wastebasket and Ananda
would not participate right she told me
about it and you wonder why she's still
getting in there this it's a very bright
kid and someone who would care and she
said that's why I wouldn't make a
monument I hope you're not mad stop that
mister same school sorry fine over will
not poach on your territory any longer I
can't come it's just impossible have
somebody sitting there was a force
against you all the time we've tried to
explain to her what we're doing the the
improvisational quality so that that
we're trying to achieve our kill when
somebody goes and really sits down at
programs everything you've been trying
to say out of existence you know you
just you feed them an idea you give them
a something to start with and then from
there they build and that's constantly
it's like the little girl building the
building in the first day Debbie
sat in the corner wouldn't do a damn
thing until I started working with her
and building something and then once she
she saw she could do it she finished
that building and I did another one well
she might not have done anything kids
make pretty things they can make cute
things and you can always end up with
something that looks very good what she
doesn't but she fails to understand is
what was occurring today is really the
planning process and that's the crux of
the whole thing whether they end up with
a model or not doesn't count things have
gotten so complicated that nobody no
really knows what the right way or the
wrong way is anymore
what all we're talking about is trying
things and taking chances and it's in
that spirit that we were supposed to be
cooperating and I didn't feel any
cooperation I was willing to bend a long
way to meet her requirements I didn't
always agree with them if I could have
discussed the problem with her
rationally but she was always suspicious
of my intent when I was trying to do
they decided there wasn't she wanted to
get other people in it yeah people
architects whoa I mean you know this
other architects smudges
know what other ones are you like mr.
Gary cuz mr. Gary after I heard you say
that she wouldn't bother with it yes
does she just went right ahead and did
it
what did you do well she just told me
she doesn't like my idea nor anything so
I just took that don't wait to it back
in the book you take the devil or the
king you did it
let's see what does she do that often to
you yeah yeah there's anybody when she
doesn't do it yeah with me right there
because that's great no she starts
laughing like is that great she says
you're a real smart boy now you got a
good ideal in there I do plan of course
to continue with my children bringing in
as they have in the past resource people
in architecture and other disciplines
which you who can work relate to
youngsters help them not give them ideas
however help them support the myth ideas
in positive ways and it bothers me you
keep saying they said what do you say
how do you feel yeah you just had you
have as much right as anybody else to
say what you say what you feel about
things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah cell doesn't seem to be taking the
kids seriously he's playing with them
like they are kids he's not seriously
involving himself with what are the
problems of planning a city or planning
the area they're involved with I don't
think anyone's taking themselves
seriously
the adults are treating the children
like children and they're behaving like
other kids are my children and I've seen
it the other way when they when they
take the roles of counseling there they
grow up they become out of your all
working for the good of people which is
great yeah we understand but now you
have to have something else to do a plan
you have to work towards a structure
everybody and put his input but I find
you're all fighting you're becoming
politicians already you know you want
the school in your Huggle and and so
forth it became apparent at that time of
the semester that we were going to have
to read plan what we had originally
thought we would do to do it well you
know are there more of these you can
think about your skill but you've got
room to make it even larger if you want
I like this one because you can go in
into the restaurant and get a cup of
coffee up the stairs right here and then
here's the walkway that you can go ahead
and go inside and you see the water when
you go inside it can also be can also be
like health food you know it's got all
kinds of food whatever kind of food you
want you know these are pavilions for
like some rock and flame on shirts and
plays and stuff like them pottery and
your lessons are knowing how to do all
that you know I can even listen and like
you can go there and see a play or a
puppet show or something like that
this one the Medical Center is a
laboratory they monument anything
special what are they - peace
[Music]
while I miss both houses right just take
these blocks and paint him and put those
little round things on him and then just
look what I made you know but like a
kindergartner could could take a block
and paint it you know and they turned
out so it's not really a city it's
mostly for maintenance
Debbie's thing was great when she did
her little wiggle and said that this is
a place for rich people and I think
that's the point there's nothing to
relate to the to the problems the that
she's confronted with in the city she
can't relate to this project she says
it's just the project for rich people
and I'm sure yeah I'm sure that was the
gist or I got the feeling that was the
gist of what she was saying and it looks
like that the more I look at it the
angrier I get you know what would happen
if someone would just build a building
and say you know I got a building you
know and people would say okay yeah me
too ciao but he never thought of what
many happened like up the building was
right in the river I guess you say yeah
well it was kind of a big space and it's
kind of hard to handle such a wide sir
I'm
like such a big place so we decided just
to take a piece out of somewhere in
Venice and then like such a big area you
know people are gonna be there's gonna
be a lot of arguments you know because
like each person say here's my little
piece right I'll say well I want this to
be maybe recreation or monument and
someone right here says no I want to put
a factory here you can't do that you
know cuz this is my plot of land you
know and that would conflict with my
factory
don't you think Jenni just what she just
said I just said she just said the whole
project right there in that last yeah
they were obviously just taking all the
conflict out of the project cuz it was
too hard to deal with it reduced it in
size because the size was didn't want to
spend the timeline it looks like that
that's a couple of hours a week
something they went to an art period
rather than that something we were
involved with totally and got into the
government and though inner workings of
it how it all fit together and discuss
the conflicts of of the transportation
versus the park versus the industry you
know Jenni said it I think in
considering doing this kind of program
again I of course would bring in the
extra people but I'd like with my
continuing kind of basis and not using
such a tremendous amount of school time
I think that's the I think it can just
work in like and be integrated into a
program as any social studies unit would
be the point she missed is that the
conflict when they start arguing with
each other that's the real involvement
in the city planning process that that
was that was they were robbed of and
that was the the kind of group activity
that we were looking for with scared
mrs. Van Arsdale
what she thought was not democratic
which was arbitrary with serendipity she
used all of those words and she felt
that that wasn't that experience was
irrelevant whereas that's really the
relevant experience and taking a piece
out of it and embellishing it and making
a beautiful object wasn't it wasn't at
all what we were trying to do
I know it good everything what people
want can have a light on their breasts
on how to plan a plan a study like this
you
you